how old are you 17. how long have you
been 17
we've always been a little suspicious
that the actors behind our favorite tv
teens weren't
actual teenagers and we were right
hollywood has always cast older actors
to play on-screen teenagers and while
sometimes it works out well
other times things can get a little
weird plus
it meant that we thought we always had
to look 30 even when we were barely 16.
again seriously bridgerton is a
certified smash hit
thanks in part to its amazing cast but
did you know that one of the youngest
characters
the feisty eloise is actually played by
one of the older cast members
that's right the 17 year old eloise is
played by actress claudia jesse who is
no less than 31 years old
how did she become a child if she's not
married and claudia
isn't the only adult in disguise hiding
in plain sight amidst the cast of the
steamiest show on netflix
she said with love love everything
stands for reason well it certainly does
not
one of the fan favorite characters
penelope is also 17
but is played on tv by irish actress
nichola cooglin who is actually 34
but thanks to her awesome abilities and
youthful appearance nicola
also plays high schooler claire in the
hilarious dairy girls
zendaya is no stranger to the spotlight
but when she first appeared as rue in
the extremely edgy high school drama
euphoria
we knew that she had officially shaken
off her disney channel reputation
i'm rue i'm jewels and while her
troubled character on the show is only
17 years old
zendaya herself is actually 24 which
in the case of euphoria is probably a
much better idea than casting a
real-life teenager
because of the kind of subject matter
that euphoria deals with and the
very unflinching way it does so it makes
total sense to us that the creators
behind the groundbreaking show would
look to actors who are slightly older
than their characters ages
like barbie ferreira who plays cat my
dream in life is to bankrupt you
while kat is 17 barbie is also 24.
there is another actress in euphoria who
is also 25 playing a 17 year old
or is she alexa demi's maddie is one of
the most intense and beloved characters
on the show and fans originally thought
that she was the same age as barbie and
zendaya
but after some very stealthy twitter
investigating
some now believe that she graduated high
school in 2008
making her closer to 30. whatever age
she is
we're just happy to have alexa on our
screens you're so sweet
but no after the smashing success of
riverdale netflix opened up the archie
comics universe and gave us the
delightfully spooky chilling adventures
of sabrina
is that a wedding dress yes it's not
fine
good you probably won't be surprised to
hear that most of the cast who are
playing teens are actually
in their 20s including jazz sinclair the
actress behind the 17 year old rosalind
walker is actually 25 years old in real
life
and speaking of riverdale there is
definitely no shortage of 20 year old
teenagers to be found having a soda at
pots
or becoming involved in a demonic cult
over there on the dark side of the cw
you know kids stuff while all of the
gang are played by actors in their 20s
you might be surprised to hear that our
very own jughead jones is played by the
eldest among them
cole sprouse who is 28 in real life in
case you haven't noticed i'm a weirdo
but he's not alone as the fan favorite
cheryl blossom is in a similar boat
cheryl is played by these stunning
madeleine patch who is actually 26
even though her character is only 18.
where are we going and how extravagant a
wardrobe should i pack
even though cole and madeleine aren't
that much older than their co-stars
we wonder if there's any onset drama
between them about it
you might actually be pretty excited to
hear that most of the young cast of
cobra kai
are actually pretty close to their
characters ages give or take a year or
two
but the same can't be said for mary
mouser who plays samantha la rousseau on
the surprise smash hit series
in the show samantha is 17 years old but
mary herself is actually 24.
even though we'll always have a soft
spot for 11 in the gang
we have to admit that steve harrington
is pretty much our favorite character on
stranger things
ahoy ladies you guys like to set sail on
this ocean of flavor with me i'll be
your captain
it was definitely a breakout role for
joe kiri who plays the unlikely teenage
heartthrob
even though he himself is now 28 years
old by the third season
steve is supposed to be 19 years old
making kiri almost a
decade older than his character it's
kind of hard to imagine a world without
robert pattinson as the actor has been a
part of our lives
ever since he emerged as the brooding
edward in the first twilight film
hello and while his character was
actually a 104 year old vampire
masquerading as a 17 year old high
school student
pattinson was already 22 when he was
first cast in the role
when tom holland first swung onto our
screens and into our hearts in
spider-man homecoming
it was clear right away that he was the
perfect choice to take over the infamous
role
and even though he was playing a 15 year
old version of peter parker the actor
was actually already 20 when he was cast
but if you think that's a big gap we
think toby maguire and andrew garfield
might have something to say about that
maguire was 26 when he first took on the
role and garfield was actually 27th
even though noah centeno has been a
hard-working young actor for almost
10 years it wasn't until his appearance
as peter kavinsky in the hit movie to
all the boys i've loved before
that he shot to genuine movie star
status
i'm way better looking than that guy and
women
everywhere were relieved to hear that
the hunky centennial was actually
not 17 as he appears on screen but in
his early 20s
when taylor zakar perez showed up as
marco pena in the kissing booth 2
he caused quite a stir
[Applause]
and we're not quite sure what high
school you go to
but ours definitely didn't feature
nothing but six foot tall hotties with
six pack abs
but on netflix anything is possible even
30 year old teenagers
yep you got it perez is actually
30 in real life even though he's playing
17 on screen
he isn't the only one in the cast who
has almost 10 years on his character
either
another new addition to the second
kissing booth movie is maisie richards
and sellers who plays
the gorgeous chloe winthrop hello
hello hello in the movie chloe is a
harvard freshman and is around
18 or 19 years old but in real life
maisie is
actually 28 years old and then of course
there is jacob allordy allordy first
burst onto our screens in the kissing
booth playing the lovable
and ridiculously good-looking noah flynn
before shaking it up on euphoria where
he plays the dangerous
and seriously damaged nate jacobs
you're abusive psychopathic
i know and while he may look like he's
actually closer to 30
ilordy is only 23 years old
usually directors have a funny habit of
casting jennifer lawrence
as way way older than she actually is
but that isn't the case for the hunger
games our very first
volunteer katniss everdeen lawrence was
20 years old when she took on the role
of 16 year old katniss everdeen and
became an international
superstar lana condor has been a very
successful actress since 2016
but the to all the boys i've loved
movies really made her a household name
don't forget to have fun yes well i have
a lot of rubbers
for that while her character in the
films lara jean covey is a 16 year old
high school student in the first film
condor was actually 21 when they started
filming and is now
23. while aidan gallagher might actually
be almost the same age as his character
number 5
or the boy on umbrella academy we might
argue that he is actually about
50 years younger see while gallagher is
16 in real life he plays the 13 year old
number 5 on the show
wouldn't your son be happier playing
with kids his own age i would rather
chew off my own
foot however since number five was
trapped in an apocalypse for 40 years or
so
it actually makes him about 58 years old
played in the harry potter films by
shirley henderson
myrtle was only 14 years old when she
became a ghost at hogwarts
but henderson herself was 37 when she
was first cast in the part
who's moaning myrtle i'm moaning
which one surprised you the most let us
know in the comments
and don't forget to hit subscribe to
keep up with all our latest videos
[Music]